NARRATOR: The West
Bank of the River Nile,
home to the world's
most iconic monuments,
the mighty pyramids of Giza.
The pyramids once housed
the bodies of the pharaohs.
But though ancient Egyptian
civilization lasted for nearly
3,000 years, its kings
only built huge tombs
like these for a few centuries.
Egyptologists are
still trying to piece
together why the
pharaohs stopped
constructing giant pyramids.
For Egyptologist Chris
Norton, the majesty
of the ancient
structures makes the fact
that Egyptians gave up building
them all the more incredible.
10 miles south of the legendary
pyramids of Giza is Saqqara.
CHRIS NAUNTON: When we
think about pyramids,
we tend to think of Giza, I
think, and the Great Pyramid
of Khufu in particular.
But actually, this is
where it all began.
NARRATOR: Chris has come to the
birthplace of pyramid building
to search for clues to why
Egyptians built giant pyramids
for less than 500 years.
Constructed a century before
the iconic pyramids at Giza,
Egypt's first pyramid is
a 200 foot tall mausoleum
of six huge limestone
platforms carefully
engineered to spread the weight
of rock and prevent collapse.
Deep inside is a giant shaft
26 feet wide and 82 feet deep.
At the bottom, the intended
final resting place
of the Pharaoh Djoser.
CHRIS NAUNTON: Ultimately
that's what it's all about.
That's where the body of a king
is going to rest in eternity.
So you've gone to
all this trouble
to create this
incredible monument
around the body of that person.
It's pretty amazing.
NARRATOR: To house his
mummy, huge chunks of granite
were slid down a
passage into the shaft
and stacked, creating
a giant sarcophagus
19 feet long and 11 feet high.
CHRIS NAUNTON: My god,
these pieces are huge.
Wow, it's amazing.
NARRATOR: But this
wasn't just a tomb
designed to secure the pharaoh's
physical body for eternity.
Crucially, for success
in the afterlife,
the pyramid ensured the king
was remembered by the living.
Completed around
2,650 BC, it sparked
an architectural revolution.
Djoser's six tier giant
wasn't just the first pyramid.
It was the world's first
monumental structure
built in stone.
Over the next century, Egypt's
kings develop the concept,
building monumental tombs all
along the Nile's West Bank,
including the first
geometrically true pyramid,
the Red Pyramid,
and the misshapen
experiment, the Bent Pyramid.
Then a dynasty of pharaohs
built the most iconic monuments
in Egypt, the pyramids of Giza.
But just a few short centuries
after the Great Pyramid
of Khufu rose from the desert,
a new era was on the horizon.